we're always getting asked how do I
program my own car key that's what we're
going to talk about today on locksmith
recommended
now we previously did a video discussing
the evolution of car keys and why they
need to be programmed to your car if you
haven't seen that it's very interesting
stuff be sure to click the link that
I'll put down below in the description
and at the end of the video if you're
I'm going to tell you how you can
program the key to your car now there's
a certain got you there I can't really
tell you that specifically for your car
every year make and model has a slightly
different set of instructions how do you
get those directions that's what I'm
going to tell you today all you need to
do to find out if the car key can be
programmed to your car is click the link
to our website down below in the
description and that'll take you to our
car remote and car key page if you just
search for your year year make and model
of car if it's on board programmable
that means you can program it yourself
you're going to see a little programming
tab right there click on that tab
that'll have the directions for your
specific year make and model if you
don't see that tab that means you cannot
do the programming on your own you're
going to have to hire somebody like
locksmith to take care of it for you now
with those directions right there just
print them out stick them in your glove
box you'll have them forever there is
one got you here that I should address
and that is car key remote combos if
your key looks something like that in
the image here a lot of times when they
combined those keys and remotes together
in one unit they actually kept the
electronics separate so you may see
programming directions for the remote
that don't apply to the key so if you go
through those instructions to program
the key to your car and the remote works
it locks it unlocks the doors but the
car won't start with the key or the car
starts and dies after just a few seconds
that means that that key needs to be
programmed separately by somebody that
can do that take it into a locksmith
shop or have a locksmith come out to you
so what did you think was this
information useful did it help you out
be sure to smash that like button
subscribe to our Channel leave a comment
down below I'm Robert you've been
watching locksmith recommended